It's great to welcome to the program today,
David Shaw, who's a data scientist who consults
with Democratic groups and has a number of
insights into many different areas of the
political world is the way I say it.
Glad, glad to have you here today.
Pleasure to be here.
So let's just start with 20, 20 polling.
I mean, how how off or on was it?
Certainly Joe Biden was winning the popular
vote polling and he won the popular vote and
he became the president.
There were certainly some states in which
the numbers leading up to the election did
not quite work out.
I mean, what's your sort of overall assessment
of what's happening with polling right now?
Yeah, well, first, as as a, I guess, disclaimer,
I think in some ways it's funny that going
into election night, we thought that Joe Biden
would win and the Democrats would get 50 or
51 Senate seats.
And, you know, the end result, Joe Biden as
president, Democrats do a 50 Senate seats.
So I think that is kind of funny.
But, you know, that said, the polling was
actually fairly bad this year, you know, just
to put numbers on it.
I think there's kind of two distinct problems
with polling.
One is just that we really the numbers were
way too high for Democrats.
On average, there was about a three percent
bias toward Democrats.
And that's in vote share, which means that
in terms of margin, you're looking at roughly
six percent.
This happened basically every level of government
on the Senate, on the House, you know, and
the presidency.
And, you know, if you were looking at polls,
you would you are coming in expecting that
Biden was going to win states like Florida,
that we would have, you know, maybe like a
bunch of Democratic seats and that we were
supposed to pick up 10 seats in the House.
And, you know, none of those things happened.
And then I think on top of that, it's not
just that the polling on average was was too
democratic, but the kind of error pattern
by state, you know, really matched what we
saw in 2016.
And, you know, what we saw in twenty eighteen
where these kind these states in the Midwest
with a lot of, you know, noncollege educated
whites, really, we saw a strong overestimation
of support.
I think there was a, you know, a Quinnipiac
poll or in Wisconsin right before the election
where it said that Biden would win by 15 and
he ended up winning by less than one.
So, yeah, I think it was a pretty bad cycle
for polling.
And then the just the last angle to recount
all the ways the polls were bad this year
is just in terms of looking at coalitions.
You know, the big changes in this election,
roughly speaking, were that non college whites
were basically where they were in 2016.
College educated whites swung something like
six or seven percent toward us.
You know, African-Americans swung two points
down.
And I think Hispanic voters, you know, now
that all the data is in, it looks like they
dropped by like nine percent and the polls
didn't really see any of those trends coming.
There was like a little bit of warning signs,
you know, with nonwhite voters that it ended
up being worse than the polls thought.
But if you looked at the polls, the polls
really told this story that we were going
to see education depolarization, that noncollege
whites were going to trend toward Democrats
and college educated whites were going to
stay basically where they were last time.
And that just didn't happen.
You know, if you look at if you just look
at the college noncollege gap, it looks like
the polls were up by something like 10 or
11 percent, which is crazy.
And a lot of ways the polls were a lot worse
than 2016.
So let's dig into one aspect of this, which
is that the concept of polling is you can't
poll everybody.
So the idea is you get a representative sample.
And what does it mean that it's representative?
Often we're talking about, well, we'll normalize
it for education or we can normalize it for
race.
We could normalize it for political affiliation.
You can normalize it for age, all of these
different things.
But one of the things you really can't normalize
for, correct me if I'm wrong, is the types
of people that are more likely to participate
in a poll versus the types of people that
are more likely to opt out.
And we heard this from some on the right who
who kind of said it as a lot of Trump ists
don't trust the polls.
So they either give deliberately fake answers
or don't participate.
And there's no great way to deal with that.
As a pollster, how much truth is there to
the general idea of people willing to and
not willing to participate and then maybe
more specifically to some of the explanations
that were given by supporters of the former
President Trump?
Yeah, I think in some ways I think there's
something to the story, I do want to be clear
that if you ask someone who they're going
to vote for in a survey, they do generally
tell you the truth.
It's not an issue trolling.
But, you know, that said, I think one of the
big drivers for why the polling was so wrong
this year and why it was actually worse than
2016 was that there were really giant differences
in who was answering the phone.
You know, something that you know, the way
that you know, the firm I worked for, the
way that they do polling, they actually match
people back to voter files.
And so we can see their party registration.
And something that was really clear is that
starting around March, Democrats became much
more likely, you know, to answer the phone
than Republicans.
And I think it's they kind of stayed at these
elevated levels throughout the entire election.
And I think there's a pretty clear story that
this had a lot to do with lock down, that
Democrats were literally home.
There's like a lot of cell phone mobility
data that really shows that Democrats stayed
home and they didn't really have much to do.
And they started answering surveys at high
rates and Republicans weren't doing that.
And, you know, they just weren't picking up
the phones.
But, you know, generalizing, you know, that
was an issue with this year.
And I think it was clear.
But even in 2016, you know, when we look back
at why the polls were wrong and I think this
bias continue now, like why is it that pollsters
have such a hard time measuring opinion in
states that have a lot of working class white
people?
And originally, people really talked about
this in terms of Trump turning out a lot of
new voters.
And I think that there's a lot of evidence
now that that's not really true, that, you
know, all of these elections, which is really
driven by people changing their minds as opposed
to changes in who voted.
But then the question is, why did why were
the polls wrong and why were the polls wrong
in more in working class areas?
And it kind of comes back to this concept
of social trust that political scientists
and sociologists like to talk about.
And so that's just operationalized with this
question of do you think that people can be
trusted or do you think that people should
keep to themselves?
And something that's pretty wild, just socially
is that, you know, the government's been asking
this on a very high quality survey.
They spend a couple of thousand dollars per
person and they get like a 70 percent response
rate.
Phone response rates are closer to one percent
just for reference point.
And they've been asking it since the 70s.
And it used to be that, you know, roughly
55 percent of people said that people could
be trusted and that figure is down to 30 percent.
So that's sociologically that's sociologically
very concerning, though, above my pay grade.
But it has measurement implications because
people who trust people who say that people
can be trusted, kind of unsurprisingly, are
a lot more likely to answer phone surveys.
And that used to not matter very much because
how much you trusted the people around you
and how much you trust institutions just used
to not be that correlated with partizanship.
But in 2016, you know, Donald Trump really
reshaped the coalition.
You know, 2012 was a poll.
It was basically, you know, a fight over whether
or not we should have universal health care.
2016 was much more of a referendum on like
how much do you trust the people around you?
And we were only talking in these surveys
to these high trust people who say that people
can be trusted.
And if you and, you know, there was literally
this hidden, you know, hidden majority of
low trust folks who went in the other direction.
And so, you know, we've actually looked at
crosstab.
And if you look among people who said that
people could be trusted, that group swung
toward Democrats by, you know, something like
four or five percent.
But the other group went completely in the
opposite direction.
And, you know, this high trust sample, that
was the people we were polling and that's
the world we expected to see on Election Day.
But then they didn't actually answer.
And, you know, the same thing.
You know, I actually you know, people don't
realize what happened in twenty eighteen Democrats
won, so they didn't notice.
But if you look at the actual margins in places
like West Virginia, places like Michigan,
places like Ohio, the elections were much
closer than people.
You know, the polls originally thought, even
if even if we ended up winning and then we
see the same thing again, you know, in in
2020.
And and I think that social justice is a very
important angle for understanding it.
One of the things I saw you to shift gears
a little bit, I read some of your tweets about,
which I find very interesting, is about the
bias of the Electoral College.
And you posted a couple of things that I find
really interesting.
One is that you posted the partizan bias of
the Electoral College over time.
And one of the things you found is that Democrats
now need about 52 percent of the vote in order
to have a 50/50 shot of winning the presidency,
given that it's not the national popular vote
that decides, but rather the electoral vote.
And then the other really interesting thing
is that there's this notion that part of what
makes the Electoral College depart in terms
of its orientation from the popular vote is
that small states are really overweighted
relative to their populations.
And you pointed out something very interesting,
which is that in terms of the difference makers,
when it comes down to who ultimately.
He wins the Electoral College.
It's more about the fact that there are some
larger population states which are relatively
close, could be 52, 48, could be 55, 45, 60,
40.
But because they are winner take all, you
are essentially I don't know if the right
word is this disenfranchizing, but if you're
part of the 42 percent of Democrats in a big
red state, your vote essentially doesn't matter
for calculating the Electoral College.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah, absolutely, I think it's just important
to say that the bias in the Electoral College,
I think is very new.
You know, it is true that, you know, Gore
won the popular vote and lost the Electoral
College, but the bias of the Electoral College
was really quite small that year.
You know, Gore got something like fifty two
point two percent.
And, you know, he had a very, very narrowly
lost.
And so that, you know, that was like random
and not really that big a deal.
And really, the Electoral College at various
points is favor Democrats.
You know, it's if if Barack Obama in 2012
had gotten about forty nine point five percent
of the vote, he actually still probably would
have won.
That's that's why people talk about the blue
wall there.
There are basically these big this is just
a little bit of a history lesson.
But, you know, there there are just these
big Midwestern states that kind of had their
economy centered around farming and manufacturing.
And as a result, you know, they have their
both, you know, relatively white and also
have relatively low education levels relative
to the rest of the country.
And the Electoral College really comes down
to who does well in these places.
And in 2012, you know, Obama, a lot of his
appeal was he actually did very well, you
know, with Midwestern whites.
He did better in the Midwest than Kerry and
really than a lot of Democrats before him.
And but he also did well enough among college
educated whites to make places like Virginia
and Colorado competitive.
So the Electoral College had like a small
bias in his favor.
2016 totally changed that, though.
And, you know, it's really great if you can
see the graph because, you know, it's kind
of wiggles around zero and then there's just
the sudden plunge to their being, I think
a three point, you know, three point gap bias
in the Republican favor.
And I think that that's, you know, the really
underappreciated part of understanding 2016,
which is that Barack Obama got about 52 percent
of the two party vote in 2012 and Hillary
Clinton got fifty one point one percent of
the vote.
And in any other democracy, that would have
been fine, you know, zero point nine percent
decline still, you know, comfortably above
50.
But the problem was that the Electoral College
shifted from being about half a point, biased
in favor of Democrats to being three points
biased in favor of Republicans.
And then that bias increased again.
And so it's helpful to put numbers on these
things.
And, you know, just to get to your other question,
I think people really don't understand why
the Electoral College causes this bias.
You know, as you said, it's not that you have
these tiny states.
It's not about Wyoming.
In order to get to 270 states, you have to
win in states like Wisconsin, like Minnesota,
like Ohio.
And there just happened to be a bunch of relatively
evenly divided states that right now are somewhat
more Republican than the country overall.
And I think that, you know, the key point
is that the reason why this happened is because
Democrats have started doing so much worse
among working class white people.
And, you know, unless that gets reversed,
I think it's unlikely that this is going to
that this is going to reverse.
You know, I think a lot of people expected
that, you know, things would get better this
year.
And the key point is that the bias went from
three points in 2016 to four points in 2020.
And so it really just shows how unworkable
our coalition is under this set of rules.
Absolutely fundamental insights to understand
really and thinking about future elections.
I mean, if you if one does not understand
reality as it is, it's hard to run a campaign
that that is based on that reality.
We've been speaking with David Shorr, who's
a data scientist who consults with democratic
groups.
You certainly should follow him on Twitter,
as I do.
David, I so appreciate your time today.
Thank you so much.
Pleasure to be here.